howdy diddly do um hi everyone if you're
wondering
what the ridiculous thing on my head is
then
that is my official graduation
successful defense hat i'm not yet
allowed to technically use the
title doctor but let's be honest who
gives a crap anyway about
titles um i'm a huge fan of this hat my
lab mates made this for me
and i thought i'd share a little bit
what's going on
right here so the everything on here
is kind of like a meme and therefore
that that has to do with me
in some way first of all you see my name
which is made up out of letters of our
lab
homepage picture which is like the
cringiest
lab homepage picture you've ever seen
where everybody's just kind of made to
hold the letter and
it's just it's very i love cringe by the
way cringe is
the best there's obviously the meme of
me
being a youtuber and having followed or
not followed my own advice
there is me as
schmidt hoover in schmidt uber attire i
went to
his talk dressed in his style to
to honor him there is two plus two
equals five which i made an extensive
video about
i made the first neural network in
minecraft
not technically true i made the first
analog neural network
in vanilla minecraft that could also do
backprop
and weight updates it's very specific
but it's the first
there are the hogging face that's a
transformer
i don't know if you can see this that's
a i don't know which one
that is that might be a decepticon
there is the asphalt set which is
my kind of side occupation as a fitness
instructor
there are the sunglasses i also like
cats
uh there is i'm always chilling for
for vin as an editor though i use knee
neovim
um yeah also the pronouns
you know gotta have them i'm you know
happy they're here there is crypto
because i'm also always chilling
for crypto sometimes for the wrong ones
but you know you can't always win
there is cheese and chocolate which is
my
standard lunch depending on the season
if i'm doing keto it's no chocolate but
you know recently
yeah just i'm swiss after all there is
yeah there is the skeleton and the sword
from minecraft again
due to my extensive research into the
technicalities of redstone
uh ili cafe five years five years of
that coffee
will you know get you through a phd
hopefully
there are the tweets
that got me into trouble yeah there is
uh
there's also trigger happy gandhi asking
you earn
80k just for a phd yes yeah we are
like the best paid phd students on the
planet it's
it's fantastic can recommend there is a
deep judge logo
which is the thing i'm going to do next
which is a legal tech startup
if you if you need legal tech please buy
our stuff
and so on the inside you'll see joe
and obviously the donald
or i'm gonna have to reattach that again
um
yeah so so because i i have lost i've
lost a bit of money betting
i bet on the you know the really old
dude and it turned out the
really old dude won so i lost somebody
uh yeah so this is this is sort of a
bunch of memes
throughout my phd i'm gonna reattach the
the vim
you know you don't wanna that dropped so
yeah
um i you know thanks to to all my lap
mates that
this is this is really cool and
yeah i'll see you around the corner
bye-bye
[Music]